about this time of year we always hear
the phrase new year new me but how can
you make that commitment towards your
health in our buddy check report Denise
Valdez talks to experts who hope that
women will put their Breast Care at the
top of their lips
[Music]
when it comes to annual mammography
screening about 66 percent of women over
40 in our state are getting it done
regularly so in this new year a push to
make that commitment and schedule your
appointment
were below the national average for
screening and we could certainly do
better Carrie Harrington is the
executive director of the Nevada cancer
Coalition a non-profit dedicated to
cancer prevention early detection
treatment and survivorship we know that
screening saves lives if you can catch
breast cancer in its earlier stages it's
much easier to treat we hear it all the
time early detection is key but some
women face barriers that make it tough
to get a mammogram every year how are
women in Nevada doing when it comes to
getting that early detection and getting
those mammograms we know we have about 2
600 women that are diagnosed with a new
case of breast cancer and we lose about
440 of our friends family neighbors to
this disease each and every year in
Nevada so the Coalition works with
health care providers hospitals and
Advocates to reach women moment
one partner is Nevada Health Centers
which runs the mammo van a mobile
mammography unit reaching Rural and
Frontier parts of the state but it also
visits the valley pretty regularly
there's also the Women's Health
connection helping the uninsured and
underinsured or those who simply fall
through the cracks it's a program funded
by the CDC and some dollars from the
state of Nevada they provide breast
cancer screening and Diagnostics as well
as cervical cancer screening with so
many resources available the Coalition
hopes that Nevada women won't have a
reason to postpone their annual
screening and as we do every month we
encourage you to call your buddy to
remind them to do their breast self-exam
Denise Valdez live local